This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the 1980s, the United States experienced a refugee crisis. Thousands of Central Americans were fleeing brutal civil wars in El Salvador and Guatemala. They were traveling north through Mexico and crossing the border into the US. We covered this history in the show last week if you haven't heard that episode yet. Go listen now. This is part two. In response to this mass migration, a network of churches across the country declared themselves
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。20世纪80年代，美国经历了一场难民危机。成千上万的中美洲人逃离萨尔瓦多和危地马拉残酷的内战。他们向北穿过墨西哥，越境进入美国。如果你还没听过那期节目，我们在上周的节目中报道过这段历史。现在就去听听吧。这是第二部分。为了回应这场大规模移民潮，全国各地的许多教堂宣布自己为
sanctuaries. That's producer Delaney Hall. In defiance of federal policy, some of these churches helped smuggle central Americans across the border and offered shelter to people who were threatened with deportation. And most of the churches did this publicly, without trying to hide what they were doing. By the mid-1980s, the sanctuary movement had become very visible and also very controversial. Here's a report that aired on NBC around that time. In the eyes of the congregation at St. Mary's Church, they are heroes.
庇护所。那是制作人德兰妮·霍尔。为了公然对抗联邦政策，其中一些教堂协助中美洲人偷渡过境，并为面临驱逐出境威胁的人提供庇护。大多数教堂都是公开这样做的，并没有试图掩盖他们的所作所为。到了20世纪80年代中期，庇护运动变得非常引人注目，同时也极具争议。以下是当时全国广播公司（NBC）播出的一则报道。在圣玛丽教堂的会众看来，他们是英雄。
In the eyes of the federal government, they are criminals who smuggle aliens into this country illegally. The government didn't like that churches were openly defined immigration law in harboring undocumented immigrants. The Immigration and Naturalization Service, now known as Immigration and Customs Enforcement,
而在联邦政府看来，他们是将外国人非法走私到这个国内的罪犯。政府不喜欢教堂公开违反移民法、窝藏无证移民。移民归化局（现称为移民及海关执法局，
or ICE, contended that many of these people didn't have legitimate asylum claims. The agency's stanceended that many of these people didn't have legitimate asylum claims. The agency's stance was that many of these migrants had come to the U.S. to find jobs, not because they feared political persecution. A refugee from El Salvador, the administration contends he and others like him have come here for economic reasons, but the young man listed other reasons for fleeing his homeland. Matanzas, killings, repression, repression, sincerity, misery, and hunger. The U.S. government found itself in a tough situation. They could allow the churches to continue openly disregarding the law, or they could launch
简称ICE）辩称，这些人中的许多人并没有合法的庇护申请。该机构的立场是，这些移民中的许多人来到美国是为了找工作，而不是因为他们害怕政治迫害。萨尔瓦多难民，政府坚称他和像他这样的人来这里是为了经济原因，但这位年轻人列出了他逃离祖国的其他原因。大屠杀、杀戮、镇压、苦难和饥饿。美国政府发现自己陷入了困境。他们可以允许教堂继续公开无视法律，或者他们可以展开
an investigation into the movement and risk public disapproval by targeting sympathetic church workers. In 1984, the government launched an investigation into the sanctuary movement. They called it Operation Sojourner, a biblical term for traveler or wanderer. The goal was to collect enough evidence to indict the leaders of the movement and to stop churches from sheltering migrants. The investigation would eventually raise big questions about the freedom of religion and the right of churches
对该运动的调查，并通过将目标对准富有同情心的教堂工作人员来冒着招致公众不满的风险。1984年，政府对庇护运动展开了调查。他们称之为“索杰纳行动”，这是一个源自《圣经》的词，意为旅行者或流浪者。其目的是收集足够的证据来起诉该运动的领导人，并阻止教堂为移民提供庇护。这项调查最终引发了关于宗教自由和教堂权利的重大问题
to declare themselves protected spaces, free from government intrusion. This is an issue that's playing out in the news again today, as churches and other institutions anticipate large-scale deportations under President Donald Trump. On day one, I'm going to begin swiftly removing criminal illegal immigrants from this country. Demonstrators outside the immigration office in Colorado, supporting a mother of four from Mexico, Genet Viscara.
宣布自己为受保护空间，免受政府干涉。随着教堂和其他机构预计唐纳德·特朗普总统治下将出现大规模驱逐出境，这个问题今天在新闻中再次上演。上任第一天，我将迅速把犯罪的非法移民驱逐出该国。科罗拉多州移民局外的示威者，支持来自墨西哥的四个孩子的母亲热内·维斯卡拉。
Currently, in 2017, many churches are starting to shelter undocumented immigrants once again. In this episode, we're going to look back at what happened in the 1980s. The last time a big confrontation happened between the federal government and sanctuary churches. In 1984, shortly after the government launched its investigation, a couple of new volunteers approached members of the sanctuary movement, asking if they could get involved. Their names were Jesus Cruz and Solomon Graham. I thought they don't fit the usual sanctuary volunteer profile, right? They look a little tough and a little too experienced on the border for the average volunteer we're
目前，在2017年，许多教堂再次开始庇护无证移民。在本期节目中，我们将回顾20世纪80年代发生的事情。上一次联邦政府与庇护教堂之间发生重大对抗是在1984年，在政府展开调查后不久，几名新志愿者接近庇护运动的成员，询问他们是否可以参与进来。他们的名字叫赫苏斯·克鲁斯和所罗门·格雷姆。我想，他们不符合通常的庇护志愿者形象，对吧？他们看起来有点强硬，对边境事务的经验也比我们招募的普通志愿者要丰富一些。
getting. This is Reverend John Fife. Back in the 1980s he was the pastor at South Side Presbyterian Church in Tucson, Arizona. He helped found the sanctuary movement. And Fife said that even though crews and grams seemed a little different somehow, it was his policy to welcome all who said they wanted to help. They had crucifixes around their necks and they presented themselves as folks who'd heard about the sanctuary movement and wanted to be a part of it, so we welcomed them and included them in. Cruz and Graham began attending meetings and helping transport Central American migrants
这是约翰·菲夫牧师。早在20世纪80年代，他是亚利桑那州图森市南区长老会教堂的牧师。他协助创立了庇护运动。菲夫说，尽管克鲁斯和格雷姆看起来有点不同，但他的政策是欢迎所有说想要帮忙的人。他们脖子上挂着十字架，把自己表现为听说过庇护运动并想成为其中一部分的人，所以我们欢迎他们并让他们加入进来。克鲁斯和格雷姆开始参加会议，并协助通过庇护网络运送中美洲移民。
through the Sanctuary Network. They would drive folks from Tucson to Phoenix, or from Phoenix to Albuquerque, or from Phoenix to LA, so they would drive legs on the Underground Railroad. But as it would turn out, crews and Graham were not ordinary volunteers. They were undercover informants. The government had hired them to infiltrate the movement and gather evidence. Crews and Graham were both former smugglers. They'd worked on the border as guides, bringing people into the country illegally.
他们会开车把人们从图森送到菲尼克斯，或者从菲尼克斯送到阿尔伯克基，或者从菲尼克斯送到洛杉矶，所以他们负责“地下铁路”的某些路段。但事实证明，克鲁斯和格雷姆并不是普通的志愿者。他们是卧底线人。政府雇用他们来渗透该运动并收集证据。克鲁斯和格雷姆都是前走私犯。他们曾在边境担任向导，非法将人带入国内。
Then they'd been caught by immigration. And they'd reached an agreement that if they would infiltrate us and inform the government about what we were doing that they would not only pay them but drop the charges against them. The INS had decided to investigate the sanctuary movement using the same tactics they might use against any criminal smuggling enterprise. The agency wasn't swayed by the religious motivations of people like Reverend Fife. Here's Alan Nelson, the then commissioner of INS, speaking with ABC in 1985. If you and I are meeting in a church building to plan to rob a bank and open with a prayer and close with a prayer, I don't think many people would say this is a church service that
然后他们被移民局抓获。他们达成了一项协议：如果他们渗透到我们内部并向政府举报我们的所作所为，政府不仅会付钱给他们，还会撤销对他们的指控。移民归化局决定使用他们可能对付任何犯罪走私团伙的相同战术来调查庇护运动。该机构并没有被像菲夫牧师这样的人的宗教动机所动摇。这是艾伦·纳尔逊，时任移民归化局局长，1985年接受美国广播公司（ABC）采访时的讲话。如果你和我为了密谋抢劫银行而在一个教堂建筑里开会，并且以祈祷开始、以祈祷结束，我想不会有多少人会说这是一个应该受到保护的宗教仪式。他们有权去想他们想的事。任何人都可以。这并不排斥他们必须遵守美国的法律。
should be protected. They have the right to think what they want. Anybody does. That doesn't exclude them from obeying the walls of the United States. This is Ruth Ann Meyers. She became the INS district director for Arizona in 1984. She didn't oversee the investigation into the sanctuary movement, but she was briefed on it when she arrived at the Phoenix office. Yeah, I was totally surprised. In my experience, I had no knowledge before of a church breaking the law and harboring illegal aliens smuggling and harboring. Meyer says the case was pretty straightforward. These people were breaking the law. pretty straightforward. These people were breaking the law.
这是露丝·安·迈尔斯。她于1984年成为移民归化局亚利桑那州地区主管。她没有监督对庇护运动的调查，但在她抵达菲尼克斯办公室时，她听取了有关简报。是的，我完全感到惊讶。以我的经验，我以前根本不知道有教堂会违法并窝藏非法外国人，进行走私和窝藏。迈尔斯说，这个案子非常简单。这些人触犯了法律。非常简单。这些人触犯了法律。
The law of the United States. I'm in favor of, excuse me, legal immigration, but not ill-legal immigration. I think we have the right to have our laws and to enforce them and decide who comes into this country and who doesn't. Cruising Graham along with a couple of other government agents, spent 10 months undercover, gathering evidence against the sanctuary workers. Their methods would eventually come under public scrutiny, because they hadn't just infiltrated the sanctuary movement.
美国的法律。我赞成，对不起，合法的移民，而不是非法的移民。我认为我们有权拥有我们的法律并执行它们，并决定谁可以进入这个国家，谁不可以。克鲁斯和格雷姆以及其他几名政府特工花了10个月的时间进行卧底，收集针对庇护工作人员的证据。他们的手段最终受到了公众的审查，因为他们不仅渗透了庇护运动。
They were also secretly recording meetings, conversations, and in some cases church services. Today's day is 1st, 1st, 4th, time is about 8 pm. We're going to deliver the needy when they come. These undercover methods struck some people as offensive and overreaching. Here's Anthony Lewis, then a professor at Harvard Law School, speaking to ABC News in 1985. All it's the methods that bother me. I think most of us Americans would believe that in America you are entitled to a sense of privacy when you go into a church, maybe privacy of a particular kind, you and you God.
他们还在秘密记录会议、对话，在某些情况下还有教堂礼拜。今天是1日，1日，4日，时间大约是晚上8点。当有需要的人来时，我们将为他们提供救助。这些卧底手段让一些人感到被冒犯和越权。这是安东尼·刘易斯，时任哈佛法学院教授，1985年接受美国ABC新闻采访时的讲话。真正困扰我的是这些手段。我想我们大多数美国人都会相信，在美利坚合众国，当你走进一座教堂时，你有权获得某种程度的隐私，也许是某种特定类型的隐私，你与你的上帝。
The state was infiltrating and secretly surveilling churches in a country where the separation of church and state is a deeply held ideal. We reached out to two agents who were involved with the case, and both declined to speak to us. The people overseeing the investigation at INS thought these methods were justified. They saw the movement as more political than religious. Yes, there were many that thought it was under the guise of the church. Meaning, the sanctuary workers were using religion as a cover to push a political
在一个政教分离被奉为深刻理想的国家里，国家正在渗透并秘密监视教堂。我们联系了两名参与此案的特工，但他们都拒绝与我们交谈。移民归化局中监督调查的人认为这些手段是正当的。他们认为这场运动具有更多的政治色彩，而不是宗教色彩。是的，有很多人认为这是以教堂为幌子。意思是，庇护工作人员正在利用宗教作为掩护来推行政治议程并破坏移民法。
agenda and undermine immigration laws. And it's true that some sanctuary volunteers were vocally critical of the American policy in Central America. Some expressed support for the left wing movements developing there. In fact, there was a divide within the movement itself about whether their works should be motivated primarily by humanitarian concerns or political ones. That debate got to the point where we decided to have a gathering and and try to resolve it. But two weeks before that meeting was supposed to happen, the government indicted 16 of the sanctuary workers in Tucson, including Reverend V. on January 14th, 1985, federal agents swept down a resting 63 Guatemalan and Salvadoran refugees across the United States and handing out indictments to 16 leaders of the sanctuary movement. That morning, Reverend Fife was sleeping when he heard someone banging on his front door.
确实，一些庇护志愿者公开批评美国在中美洲的政策。一些人表示支持在那里发展起来的左翼运动。事实上，运动内部本身就存在分歧，即他们的工作究竟应该主要由人道主义关切驱动，还是由政治关切驱动。这场辩论发展到我们决定举行一次集会并试图解决它的地步。但在该会议召开前两周，政府在图森起诉了16名庇护工作人员，其中包括V牧师。1985年1月14日，联邦特工雷霆出击，在全美逮捕了63名危地马拉和萨尔瓦多难民，并向庇护运动的16名领导人发出了起诉书。那天早上，菲夫牧师正在睡觉，突然听到有人敲他的前门。
And so I got up and I went to the door and there were two border patrol agents here. His immediate concern was for the refugees that were staying at Southside Presbyterian Church right across the street from his house. The only thought that occurred to me was I got all these vulnerable people over in the church. I need to keep these guys occupied. So I invited him in, made coffee, stalled every way I could. He read through the entire indictment the officers had handed him, trying to buy some time.
于是我起床走到门前，那里有两个边境巡逻特工。他最关心的留在南区长老会教堂的难民，那座教堂就在他家马路对面。我脑子里唯一闪过的念头是，我在教堂里有这么多弱势群体。我得想办法拖住这几个人。所以我请他们进来，煮了咖啡，用我能想到的各种方法拖延时间。他仔细阅读了官员交给他的整份起诉书，试图争取一些时间。
My charges were pretty clear and they were pretty typical of everyone. They were a number of counts of conspiracy to violate federal law, harboring illegal aliens, transporting illegal aliens, and eating illegal aliens. And everyone had different counts under each of those categories. Eventually, the Border Patrol agents went on their way, and Reverend Fife and the other leaders of the sanctuary movement were left with a daunting situation. They faced an impending, high-profile trial in which they'd be facing off with the federal
我的罪名相当明确，而且对每个人来说都非常典型。它们包括多项串谋违反联邦法律、窝藏非法外国人、运送非法外国人以及协助非法夫外国人的罪名。每个人在每个类别下都有不同的罪名。最终，边境巡逻特工离开了，菲夫牧师和庇护运动的其他领导人陷入了令人望而生畏的境地。他们面临着一场即将到来、备受瞩目的审判，在审判中他们将与联邦政府正面交锋。
government. And the charges against them were serious. If convicted, they could spend years in prison. They got to work assembling a team of lawyers to defend them. So there's two bases as I see it for sanctuary. It's very simple, really. to defend them. So there's two bases as I see it for sanctuary. It's very simple, really. This is James Brazenham, one of the defense lawyers.
对他们的指控非常严重。如果被定罪，他们可能会在监狱里度过多年。他们开始着手组装一个律师团队来为自己辩护。所以在我看来，庇护有两个基础。这其实很简单。为自己辩护。所以在我看来，庇护有两个基础。这其实很简单。这是詹姆斯·布拉森汉，辩护律师之一。
The first is religion, and many churches, many religions, have as a distinct imperative that you are to assist people who are on the road and who are fleeing some form of violence oppression. It's the teaching of Jesus. The defense thought there was an argument to be made that the sanctuary workers were just acting in accordance with their faith. Not only that, the lawyers believed the religious rights of the sanctuary workers had been violated by the government agents who'd infiltrated their churches and
第一个是宗教，许多教堂、许多宗教都有一个明确的命令，即你必须帮助在路上逃避某种形式的暴力压迫的人。这是耶稣的教导。辩护方认为，有一个论点可以站住脚，即庇护工作人员只是在按照他们的信仰行事。不仅如此，律师们认为，渗透到他们的教堂并进行秘密录音的政府特工侵犯了庇护工作人员的宗教权利。
made secret recordings. And that's intimidation of people who are pursuing their Bible studies in a church. The second part of the Defences' argument had to do with asylum law. The law provides that when a person shows up at the border and they are fleeing certain specific kinds of oppression or violence, they have a right to come in. And when that is true and that can be established in an immigration court, that person is entitled to stay in the United States.
这是对在教堂里进行圣经学习的人的恐吓。辩护方论点的第二部分与庇护法有关。该法律规定，当一个人出现在边境并且他们正在逃离某些特定类型的压迫或暴力时，他们有权进来。当情况确实如此并且可以在移民法庭上得到证实，这个人就有权留在美国。
That's asylum. As the defense team researched the laws, they started to believe that their clients hadn't really violated the law at all. They thought the US government had. I did research both how the United States government was handling asylum applications from people from Central America, and I also researched international law. This is A-Bates Butler III, another lawyer for the sanctuary volunteers. And I was appalled by what I discovered about how the United States government was systematically
这就是庇护。随着辩护团队对法律的研究，他们开始相信他们的客户根本没有违反法律。他们认为违反法律的是美国政府。我研究了美国政府是如何处理来自中美洲的人的庇护申请的，我还研究了国际法。这是A·贝茨·巴特勒三世，庇护志愿者的另一位律师。我对我的发现感到震惊，关于美国政府是如何系统性地——
it seemed denying asylum applications from Central America. This was all happening in the context of a major shift in US refugee policy. Before 1980, the US approached to taking in refugees had been expressly political. It gave preference to refugees fleeing communist countries and countries in the Middle East. In 1980, President Carter signed the Refugee Act into law. The law was supposed to create a fairer system by adopting a more humanitarian non-ideological definition of a refugee. It used the criteria developed by the United Nations, which identified a refugee as anyone with a well-founded fear of persecution based on race, religion, nationality, social group, or political opinion.
似乎在拒绝来自中美洲的庇护申请。这一切都发生在美利坚合众国难民政策发生重大转变的背景下。1980年之前，美国接收难民的方法一直是明确政治化的。它优先考虑逃离共产主义国家和中东国家的难民。1980年，卡特总统签署了《难民法》成为法律。该法律本应通过采用对难民更具人道主义、非意识形态的定义来创建一个更公平的系统。它使用了联合国制定的标准，将难民定义为任何因种族、宗教、国籍、社会群体或政治见解而有充分理由害怕受到迫害的人。
Even though these new criteria were in place when Reagan came into office, the lawyers for the sanctuary workers believed the government was not following its own law. They thought INS was turning away large numbers of balsavadorans and Guatemalans who should have qualified as political refugees. Butler had been skeptical of the sanctuary movement when he first learned about it, but his research had changed his mind.
尽管里根上台时这些新标准已经到位，但庇护志愿者的律师认为政府并没有遵守自己的法律。他们认为移民归化局拒绝了大量本来应该有资格成为政治难民的萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人。巴特勒最初了解庇护运动时对它持怀疑态度，但他的研究改变了他的想法。
And so I moved from a position of, well, this is all fine and dandy and this is the religious thing to do, but it's illegal. I moved from that position to it's lawful to help these people and it's the United States government that is violating the law. The defendants and their supporters marched to the federal building in Phoenix for the first round of arrangements this morning. The charges transporting aliens illegally, harboring them, and conspiracy. Inside the courtroom, the defendants pleaded not guilty.
所以我从“好吧，这很好很棒，这是符合宗教信仰的事，但它是违法的”这种立场转变了。我从那个立场转变为“帮助这些人是合法的，违反法律的是美国政府”。被告和他们的支持者今天上午游行前往菲尼克斯的联邦大楼进行第一轮传讯。指控是非法运送外国人、窝藏他们和共谋。在法庭内，被告表示不认罪。
They were released without bail. Their trials were set for April 2nd. The sanctuary people say those trials will be a major test of religious freedoms in this country. This afternoon in Tucson, more arrangements. After months of preparation, the defense team was feeling confident. They thought they had sympathetic clients, a good amount of public support, and compelling legal arguments.
他们被无保释释放。他们的审判定于4月2日进行。庇护人士表示，这些审判将是对这个国家宗教自由的一次重大考验。今天下午在图森，有更多的传讯。经过几个月的准备，辩护团队信心十足。他们认为他们有富有同情心的客户、大量的公众支持以及令人信服的法律论据。
Here's Revan 5 again. Our position was, oh, we welcome the opportunity to make that case in court. And we think we're gonna win in a slam dunk. But then, very early on, the defense team faced a major setback. The lead prosecutor for the government was a lawyer named Donald Reno Jr.
再次请出雷万·5。我们的立场是，哦，我们欢迎有机会在法庭上提出这个案件。我们认为我们会大胜而归。但随后，在很早的时候，辩护团队就遭遇了一次重大挫折。政府的首席检察官是一位名叫唐纳德·里诺二审的律师。
And one of his first moves was to file a series of motions, asking the federal judge who was hearing the case to limit the arguments the defense could make. And then the federal judge who was hearing our case ruled that we couldn't say anything in our defense during our trial, about five subjects. United States Refugee Law, International Refugee refugee law, conditions in El Salvador, conditions in Guatemala, or religious faith. So that wiped out our entire legal position.
他的首要行动之一就是提交了一系列动议，要求审理此案的联邦法官限制辩护方可以提出的辩护理由。然后审理我们案件的联邦法官裁定，在我们的审判期间，我们不能就五个主题进行任何为自己辩解的发言。美国难民法、国际难民法、萨尔瓦多局势、危地马拉局势或宗教信仰。这彻底抹杀了我们的整个法律立场。
I mean, what was left? Nothing was left. And the way my attorney explained it was, well, federal judges in criminal prosecutions have enormous power to exclude evidence that they believe is not relevant to the charges that are being filed against the defendant. The judge had effectively reduced the case to its most basic level. Had the sanctuary workers engaged in a conspiracy to smuggle and harbor undocumented people? Yes or no?
我的意思是，还剩下什么？什么都没剩下。我的律师解释说，好吧，联邦法官在刑事诉讼中拥有巨大的权力，可以排除他们认为与对被告提出的指控无关的证据。法官实际上将案件简化到了最基本的层面。庇护工作人员是否参与了走私和窝藏无证人员的共谋？是还是不是？
There was to be no discussion about context, history, or motivations. One of the defendants was a man named Jim Corbett. Along with Reverend Fife, he'd helped to found the sanctuary movement. Corbett died in 2001, but in an archival interview, he described the situation that the defense team found itself in. He said it was as if a man was driving late at night in freezing weather. His car breaks down, so he goes to a nearby house and breaks in and then is discovered and brought to trial. And the judge rules out any evidence that would indicate that it was 40 below. His car had gone bad, he had had stopped, went to the only house in the area and entered it.
不准讨论背景、历史或动机。其中一名被告是一个名叫吉姆·科尔贝特的人。他与菲夫牧师一起协助创立了庇护运动。科尔贝特于2001年去世，但在一次档案采访中，他描述了辩护团队发现自己所处的情境。他说，这就好像一个人在深夜寒冷的天气里开车。他的车坏了，于是他走到附近的一所房子里破门而入，然后被发现并被送上法庭。法官排除了任何能表明当时气温是零下40度的证据。他的车坏了，他停了下来，去了该地区唯一的房子并走了进去。
Without understanding the context, Jim thought there was no way that jury could understand why the sanctuary workers had decided to shelter Central Americans. Now, in terms of the necessity defense, we're talking about something very similar with people fleeing torture and murder in a very different context, but to rule out the ability to refer to that necessity simply makes a mockery of the law. The judge named Earl Carroll died in early February of 2017. We requested an interview with prosecutor Donald Reno Jr. but he's still an active litigator for what's now known as
如果不了解背景，吉姆认为陪审团绝不可能理解为什么庇护工作人员决定为中美洲人提供庇护。现在，就紧急避险辩护而言，我们谈论的是非常相似的事情，人们在截然不同的背景下逃离酷刑和谋杀，但排除提及这种紧急避险的能力简直是对法律的嘲弄。名叫厄尔·卡罗尔的法官于2017年2月初去世。我们请求采访检察官唐纳德·里诺二世，但他目前仍然是现在被称为移民及海关执法局的机构的活跃诉讼律师。
Immigration and Customs Enforcement. The agency declined our request to speak with him. But he was featured in a news report from 1985 and he described the sanctuary movement as quote, an alien smuggling conspiracy. The government says that's not much different from drug smuggling. Over the next several months, the prosecution laid out its case against the sanctuary workers, relying heavily on testimony from their undercover informants. Reno characterized the sanctuary movement as a smuggling operation, pure and simple. The defense team tried to undermine those accounts in cross-examination
该机构拒绝了我们与他交谈的请求。但他出现在1985年的一篇新闻报道中，他将庇护运动描述为“一个外国人走私阴谋”。政府表示，这与走私毒品没什么不同。在接下来的几个月里，控方陈述了对庇护工作人员的指控，在很大程度上依赖于他们的卧底线人的证词。里诺将庇护运动定性为一个走私行动，简单纯粹。辩护团队试图在交叉盘问中削弱这些说法，
and to sneak in details about context and motivation when they could. But in most ways, their hands were tied. And when it came time for the defense to present their case, they declined to put anyone on the stand. The defense arrested without questioning a stand. The jury deliberated for more than 48 hours, spread over nine days. On May 1, 1986, 16 months after the indictments and more than six months since the start of
并在可能的时候偷偷塞进关于背景和动机的细节。但在大多数情况下，他们的手脚被绑住了。当轮到辩护方陈述他们的案子时，他们拒绝让任何人出庭作证。辩护方在没有对证人进行盘问的情况下宣告休息。陪审团进行了超过48小时的审议，分散在九天内。1986年5月1日，在起诉书发出16个月后、审判开始六个多月后，陪审团步入法庭宣读裁决。
the trial, the jury filed into the courtroom to read the verdict. Of the 11 sanctuary workers who went to trial, three were acquitted of all charges. Eight were found guilty, including Reverend V, which hit Bates Butler, the lawyer, really hard. After the jury came in, I was so disgusted. With the system that I had worked in for so long I didn't want to be a part of it. And we were so upset that our government and our court system had cast aside our clients with their moral positions and that we felt like the government and the courts were bankrupt. The system was bankrupt.
在受审的11名庇护工作人员中，3人被宣判无罪。8人被判有罪，其中包括V牧师，这给律师贝茨·巴特勒带来了沉重的打击。陪审团得出结论后，我对这个我工作了这么久的体制感到如此恶心，以至于我不想再成为它的一部分。我们感到非常沮丧，因为我们的政府和我们的法院系统抛弃了我们的客户和他们的道德立场，我们觉得政府和法院已经破产了。这个系统破产了。
But the other defense lawyer, James Brazenhan, had known there were significant hurdles they needed to overcome. You know, Joyce are very good, but they they come into the box with their own attitude. And the attitude is people just can't come over the border. If you're gonna do that, you gotta pay the price. Ruth Ann Meyers of the INS thought the verdict was fair. The people that worked in the sanctuary movement did not present those people to immigration offices.
但另一位辩护律师詹姆斯·布拉森汉深知他们需要克服重大的障碍。你知道，陪审团非常好，但他们带着自己的态度走进陪审团席。这种态度是人们不能就这样越过边境。如果你要这么做，你得付出代价。移民归化局的露丝·安·迈尔斯认为这一裁决是公正的。在庇护运动中工作的人并没有将这些人带到移民办公室。
They smuggled them into the U.S. They gave them, quote, sanctuary in their churches. They did not follow the law. Next came the sentencing by the judge. We really were worried that the judge was gonna put him in prison. My attorney told me, take a toothbrush in your hip pocket when you go to sentencing because they want you bad.
他们把他们走私进美国。他们在他们的教堂里给他们所谓的“庇护”。他们没有遵守法律。接下来是法官的量刑。我们真的很担心法官会把他送进监狱。我的律师告诉我，去听判决时在后裤兜里带上一把牙刷，因为他们恨死你了。
toothbrush in your hip pocket when you go to sentencing because they want you bad. So I had made arrangements with the congregation and with my family and everything, expecting to go to prison. And much to our astonishment, he sent and install of us who were convicted to five years' probation. The judge gave them relatively lenient sentences, considering they'd been convicted of in some cases, felonies. So we were relieved at that point. I think I don't know what he thought, but I thought that if he gave these nice people
去听判决时在后裤兜里带上一把牙刷，因为他们恨死你了。所以我已经和会众、我的家人以及一切做好了安排，做好了进监狱的准备。令我们大为惊奇的是，他判处我们所有被定罪的人五年缓刑。考虑到他们在某些情况下被判犯有重罪，法官对他们的判决相对较轻。所以我们在那个时候松了一口气。我想我不知道他是怎么想的，但我认为如果他给这些好人判处监禁，那就太糟糕了。
jail term, it would be awful. The public opinion on that. And I think he had some sense that that might be true. Many of the sanctuary workers, including Reverend Fife, went back to their communities and continued their work in the sanctuary movement. Churches continued sheltering people. Volunteers continued helping people across the border. Many of the sanctuary volunteers had made clear in their closing arguments in the trial that they wouldn't stop doing the work.
公众对此的看法。我想他某种程度上也意识到了这一点可能是真的。许多庇护工作人员，包括菲夫牧师，回到了他们的社区，继续他们在庇护运动中的工作。教堂继续为人们提供庇护。志愿者继续帮助人们过境。许多庇护志愿者在审判的结案陈词中明确表示，他们不会停止这项工作。
The government may have sentenced John Fife and seven others sanctuary activists, but it is hardly silenced them nor stopped them from across country crusade. In fact. And at that point, did the government just back off? I mean, they must have known that you were continuing to do exactly what they'd just tried you for. They backed off us here in Tucson, but they tried one more trial. In New Mexico, the government charged a man and a woman who were part of the sanctuary
政府可能判处了约翰·菲夫和其他七名庇护活动人士刑罚，但这几乎没有让（他们）噤声，也没有阻止他们发起全国性的运动。事实上。而在那个时候，政府就此罢手了吗？我的意思是，他们一定知道你们在继续做他们刚刚审判你们的事情。他们在图森对我们罢手了，但他们又进行了一次审判。在新墨西哥州，政府起诉了一名参与庇护运动的男子和一名女子，指控他们运送无证移民。
movement for transporting undocumented immigrants. And the jury in that case found them not guilty. And at that point, we knew that the movement had grown to the point where juries would no longer convict sanctuary workers. Not long after the criminal trial had ended, a group of churches and refugee rights organizations filed a class action lawsuit against the government. They alleged, among other things, that the government had engaged in discriminatory treatment of asylum claims made by Guana Mollens and Salvadorans. In 1990, the government settled the lawsuit.
该案的陪审团裁定他们无罪。就在那个时候，我们知道这场运动已经发展到陪审团不再给庇护工作人员定罪的地步了。刑事审判结束后不久，一群教堂和难民权利组织对政府提起了集体诉讼。他们指控，除其他事项外，政府对危地马拉人和萨尔瓦多人提出的庇护申请进行了歧视性对待。1990年，政府就该诉讼达成和解。
They agreed to give everyone who was here without documents from those countries, temporary protected status, work permits, and they agreed to a whole series of reforms of the political asylum process. So we essentially began to wind down this sanctuary movement. But even though the churches were slowing their work, the whole idea of sanctuary was spreading. College campuses, cities, counties, even whole states began to declare themselves sanctuaries, and not just for refugees fleeing persecution, but for undocumented people more broadly. This accelerated through the 1980s and has continued up to today. But what exactly sanctuary means varies from place to place?
他们同意给予所有从这些国家无证来到这里的人临时保护身份、工作许可，并同意对政治庇护程序进行一系列改革。所以我们基本上开始缩减这个庇护运动。但即便教堂放慢了他们的工作速度，庇护的整个理念却在蔓延。大学校园、城市、县，甚至整个州都开始宣布自己为庇护所，不仅为逃离迫害的难民提供庇护，更广泛地为无证人员提供庇护。这在20世纪80年代加速发展，并一直持续到今天。但庇护的具体含义因地而异。
Anything you want. That's part of the problem. And each city is probably a little bit different. Once again, lawyer James Brosnahan. Usually, the local authorities, police, sheriffs will not assist in the deportation of undocumented people. In some places, police aren't allowed to inquire about a person's immigration status, or to give that information to the federal government. In other places, all residents are promised access to city services, regardless of their
任何你想要的。这就是问题的一部分。每个城市可能都有点不同。再次有请律师詹姆斯·布鲁斯纳汉。通常，地方当局、警察、治安官不会协助驱逐无证人员。在某些地方，警察不得询问一个人的移民状态，也不得将该信息提供给联邦政府。在其他地方，所有居民都被承诺可以使用城市服务，无论他们的移民状态如何。
immigration status. These policies can be set in law, or they can just happen in practice. President Donald Trump talked a lot about sanctuary cities during his campaign, and he's pointed to murders committed by undocumented immigrants as evidence that sanctuary cities should not exist. He's threatened to pull federal funding from cities that identify as sanctuaries, and he's also promised to accelerate deportations. In response, churches are once again sheltering people. I think a lot of congregations across the nation are struggling with what
这些政策可以写入法律，也可以只是在实践中发生。唐纳德·特朗普总统在竞选期间谈论了很多关于庇护城市的话题，他指出无证移民犯下的谋杀案作为庇护城市不应存在的证据。他威胁要从认定为庇护所的城市撤回联邦资金，他还承诺加速驱逐出境。作为回应，教堂再次为人们提供庇护。我认为全国许多会众都在努力应对，在现政府领导下，忠于我们信仰的要求意味着什么。
will it mean to be faithful to the mandates of our faith underneath this administration. This is Alison Harrington. She's the current pastor of Southside Presbyterian in Tucson. The church where the sanctuary movement began in the 1980s. She and her congregation provided sanctuary to a couple of people who were threatened with deportation during the Obama administration. They're now having conversations about whether that work will expand in the next few years.
这是爱莉森·哈灵顿。她是图森市南区长老会教堂的现任牧师。这座教堂正是20世纪80年代庇护运动的发源地。她和她的会众在奥巴马政府期间为一对面临驱逐出境威胁的人提供了庇护。他们现在正在讨论这项工作是否会在未来几年扩大。
I mean, I can't ignore the fact that my predecessor, John Fife, was indicted for doing the work that I'm doing right now and that he was looking at 10 years in prison. I try not to think about that, but you can't ignore that. Since 2011, churches have had some protected status as sanctuaries. In that year, immigration and customs enforcement
我的意思是，我无法忽视这样一个事实：我的前任约翰·菲夫因为做我现在正在做的工作而被起诉，他当时面临着10年的监禁。我尽量不去想那个，但你无法忽视这一点。自2011年以来，教堂作为庇护所获得了一些受保护的身份。那一年，移民及海关执法局
under President Obama issued a memo. It said that some sensitive locations require special consideration by immigration officers. The government has said we won't enter into those sensitive locations unless it's an extreme situation or we have higher levels of approval and those sensitive locations are houses of worship, hospitals, and schools. But that practice isn't codified into law, and could easily change. Recently, there have been reports of immigration agents targeting undocumented people in hospitals and schools.
在奥巴马总统任期内发布了一份备忘录。它说，一些敏感地点需要移民官员的特别考虑。政府已经表示，除非是极端情况或我们拥有更高水平的批准，否则我们不会进入这些敏感地点，这些敏感地点是礼拜场所、医院和学校。但这种做法并没有编入法律，而且很容易改变。最近，有报道称移民特工在医院和学校针对无证人员。
Churches might also be vulnerable. That's going to have to be worked out through a number of institutional decisions as well as court decisions decisions well into the future. What's going to be the result five years from now? We'll see. No one knows. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Delaney Hall, with Sharifusif, Avery Trollfoman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, and Terran Mazza is our office manager.
教堂也可能是脆弱的。这必须通过许多机构决定以及法院决定在未来很长一段时间内得到解决。五年后的结果会是什么？我们拭目以待。没有人知道。“99%隐形”本周由德兰妮·霍尔制作，合作者包括谢里夫·尤瑟夫、埃弗里·特罗尔弗曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马尔斯。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，泰兰·马扎是我们的办公室经理。
Sean Rial composed original music for this episode with additional music by Ok Akumi and Melodium. Thank you to Miriam Davidson, the author of Convictions of the Heart for letting us use tape of her interview with Jim Corbett. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI work.
肖恩·里亚尔为本期节目创作了原创音乐，附加音乐由奥克·阿库米和梅洛迪姆提供。感谢《信念的心》一书的作者米里亚姆·戴维森允许我们使用她对吉姆·科尔贝特的采访录音。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的电台街制作。您可以在脸书上找到该节目并参与关于该程序的讨论。你可以在推特上@我罗曼·马尔斯，或@节目99PI工作。
We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But the nexus of all things 99PI is at 99PI. Duttlework. All things 99PI is at 99PI.org. Radio TPI. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram和Tumblr上。但所有99PI事务的核心都在99PI.dot.work。所有99PI事务都在99PI.org。电台TPI。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。